welcome to my humble abode yeah great
this
is where it all started oh really yeah
oh this is the council this is the
council flag
it's it's quite nice for a council for
it it's a nice crowd yeah nice area
i would think it would be a perfect
service foundation yeah that's what i
think it's not far from where our old
offices were you know no i know you're a
great politician yeah that's why i gave
my life to christ
yeah very true but yeah so um this is it
um
i'm currently actually going to be
converting it into
a one bedroom so it's got planning to
have
um an extension on the rear um
unfortunately it can't be
too big so it can only really be a
bathroom it's not big enough for a room
you're gonna put a bathroom down there
from down there and then um the kitchen
will be the bedroom
so i'm hoping to take all of this out
but also all of this
so obviously that's the current bathroom
at the moment so i'm hoping just to
make it one nice sized room so hold on
so you're gonna knock that wall down and
then this will be
a bedroom and then once this is a
bedroom
oh it then goes from a studio
so this will be a kitchen diamond
gallery i'm thinking to open up this bit
here and have
some the bathroom will be back in the
day
yeah so the kitchen will be in here i
was gonna do it across here but i think
it'll be better if it's in there
you know what's really interesting about
london that conversion
would one billion percent not be worth
it in huddersfield oh here it's like
everything yeah
yeah but in huddersfield it's like it's
probably gonna cost you how much to do
that conversion mic
thirty-five thousand literally right
there we go yeah but then you'll
probably add 70 grams value
it's gonna go to 550 from what is it
440.
110 yeah well it's gone up in value by
42
because of the whole so how much value
yeah how much value
yeah um well put in a bathroom here
and then turning this into a bedroom
like what's it worth
right now and what will it be worth so
at the moment it's worth
um 482 and it'll be worth 550.
so it's gonna add
so is that how much it actually is going
to add okay
yeah it's funny that i was like it'll
probably cost 35 grand and then it would
be worth
it
it would cost probably 30 grand maybe 25
30 grand to do it
and it would add probably 10 grand yeah
so that's actually yeah
yeah but london's so prime i mean yeah
the thing is
it would be it's the rental as well it
needs an update that's it but it's about
the rental as well
um it brings a few extra hundred pounds
on top so
worth it it means that it covers itself
completely
also as well um did you say that it was
like
you needed to extend the lease or
something here or was that am i
remembering things like without another
property the lease is for 125 years
what what am i getting confused i'm sure
you had a property where
the lease was around the corner from
here what's that property
i never got it or anything something to
do with me yeah
i never got it it was a bloody good deal
but if you can extend the knees
but i think that's for people that are
experts in that area i'm not sure
about it yeah i am going to put planning
permission for a loft conversion are
they doing it in the street already
before the legislation came in that it's
not a conservational area but
most people that have been put in
applications over the last six years
have been denied do you
not now because you're trying to film is
this fun
do you know what when i was in
huddersfield i was like yeah i'm just
going to develop it and just rent it out
but as soon as i got back here and
looked at everything
i was like this actually is home and i
didn't even know
i had fun here at the moment no one
tenants have moved out when did they
move out
yesterday oh wow just moved out don't
waste any time no
no okay cool so you're gonna
spend about 35k turn into turn it from a
studio to a one bed
see if you can get planning to do a loft
conversion
push the value right up and then
refinance it yeah and then get higher
rent
how much were you renting it for just
now i was renting it for 1200 inclusive
of utilities so really cheap
yeah so it wasn't going right as it is
uh uh as is probably about 14
excluding um utilities
what do you mean excluding so i was
renting it including all the utilities
they're just getting a flat rate
whereas you could do it fourteen hundred
they would have to pay their own bills
and then when it's
if you were to get a bathroom there
would it be more like 1700
exactly that yeah great great so it's
worth doing
yeah because i can refinance it and pull
the money back out the deal yeah and
you're adding 300 pounds a month
for 35 grand yeah and it's not even cash
because you're gonna get it back anyway
it just makes perfect sense i mean i
would love for it to be a service
accommodation i feel like it would
really work for that but i think i'd
have to speak to
the freehold about that so um
do you know what though it's a really
nice home it is a nice home
and if you rent it out for 1600 once
it's a one bed
um it will just rent out beautifully
they'll stay a long
yeah yeah so i mean it's exciting stuff
um i definitely
my sister's actually going to be doing
it eeg management so she's
uh she's got her own construction
company um and she's going to be
developing it first
hand which is super exciting and she
said it's
going to take six weeks nice so we
should be done
in about two months that's incredible i
know such good stuff
i'll show you actually i should just
fire up my laptop um
so i'm buying a house in barnsley at the
moment
so i want you to see it yeah
um i'm really pleased to hear that
you're getting you'll definitely be a
millionaire very soon
well i've already calculated it between
this house green head and this new house
that we're getting
if i don't take out all the equity we're
at 750
equity jail's getting close
and it's literally being only a few
months six months six months six months
do you reckon why
in another six months drinking water
you're doing it over the years yeah
definitely
definitely that's exciting definitely
within a year
within six months from now once
everything's purchased and added value
to it
yeah so hold on so so six months ago was
when you moved to
huddersfield from london you've got your
property which is now being done up
which is almost finished
it's done done today right you're gonna
make
a nice bit of profit on that messiah
please you've got this
flat which you bought eight minutes ago
yeah which you're about to add value to
and push the guy up and they've got this
third one which fingers crossed you're
going to compete on in the next couple
of months yeah um so we need probably
one or two more deals yeah by the end of
the year and then boom
and then boom shaka will have janelle's
spooner
the millionaire yeah nets that's awesome
that's awesome based on if i don't
obviously refinance which i am doing
yeah i'm very happy i'm very blessed man
oh my god
make me wanna have another one um
i did have it saved i kind of deleted
everything okay
yeah so i really think this grandfather
writes that's why i specifically looked
in this area
um
the scary thing is when he laughs a lot
i actually feel like he does understand
i'm pretty confident that it does it's
easy
oh it's another nice one isn't it yeah
it's another nice
one it's very grand
very very grand okay
it's just got so much to it so that that
main house could easily be in nine
bedrooms
this is probably a little bigger than
the one you've just done isn't it it is
so you kind of slowly move it that's the
point isn't it
i reckon as well once you've done this
one your third big one
you should go bigger again yeah in fact
i've got a piece of land
that i'm in the process of buying it
leaves yeah
yeah no no another one oh another one
another one
um just just outside of lisa she's
technically in bradford but it's like
the nice part of bradford
um so that's going through now i'll show
you around that
okay amazing that'll be amazing yeah um
for sure that's gonna be 30 houses
stop yeah that's a big one that's
literally like
what i want to do next that's what you
need to do next literally we'll do that
i even my builders said 100 percent even
my builders said
that they would like georgetown yeah
they would do like the building
wow
literally sorry do you know what if
they've said that let's
are they good do they build houses and
stuff i mean i haven't seen any of their
houses so i think that would be worth
like having a look at because they're
talking about a lot of houses but they
want to they keep bringing me to sites
and saying they want to build six i love
how this just came on the market and you
just snapped it up as well yeah
i mean it was on for they reduced it
because it was on for f it was valued at
5.80
and we and we got it at 5.50 so
so you're going to turn this into two
apartments and then a hmr
yeah because it's got grandfather rights
and the hmo
will be um how many rooms nine
and two apartments
the whole point isn't it to just get to
this point of like having that network
because then
network net worth because then we can
really like because obviously this is
all being done off of the education
from the um the academy
do you know what i mean because even
like lease option agreement like i'm
selling deals now like well they haven't
sold yet but they're all going out there
and stuff
so i'm doing all of that stuff you know
i've
just done rent to rent in the past at
least option agreement
i wouldn't have known that if i didn't
do the academy so now that i've
like got a lease option agreement that's
also showing
like you've always said the bag full of
different tools yeah yeah you know what
i mean like that's what the academy
no i'm not doing them i'm not doing them
did you change your mind i changed my
mind
i i stopped i stopped immediately yeah
um i focused on deal sourcing you're
sort of inspired it's quick cash
it's quick cash but it's a lot of work
yeah and that that that's
that's what that's the challenge but i
don't mind i've got so much money
no you're not really confused mate yeah
for you
deal sourcing should not be a lot of
work let me tell you why
no because you're already out there
viewing houses for you
yeah any houses that you find that don't
quite fit your criteria
you should be and you shouldn't have a
problem selling them because i'm
branding you quite well yeah
people know who you are you shouldn't
have any issues
to be honest it has been
like i don't think that the actual
selling of the house is gonna be
an issue um the deals are an issue now
that i've created a system that works
for me so i've now got that time to
actually what's the hardship then what's
the problem oh it's always the academic
for me
it's always academic it's always putting
it together oh the email the image
all day long is the hard part is like
sitting because i
i can't work academically with
distraction so as soon as you run around
it i i lose it so that's the world
well that you struggle with is actually
the easy bit
i know well now it's because it's
starting to have you got a system now
then you've got all these yeah yeah yeah
i've got i've got a system so this is
the other property this is the one
that's a lease option agreement
okay um obviously i have a bit of a
theme when it comes to my houses
i can see yeah okay so have you have you
actually a green elite option on this
yeah so
the the so everything's been agreed um
um the split after seven years is 50 50
on
on capital appreciation okay um and i
have to pay her 1500
months it's quite high but i've got an
estate agent who has a lot of
working professionals that work in the
local um hospital
that need room to stay in and because it
was an old care home it's already got
ensuite bathrooms
fire doors what's that everything how
much do you reckon
you will make in
um monthly profit on it it's about four
thousand probably a little bit more
four thousand profit no not profit no
profit is about one thousand
five uh rents four thousand yeah and
then
after costs it's about one thousand
eight
is what i thought i wrote down but it
wow
that's a great deal and and and please
can dress in all the contracts for you
right now yes
is he doing it fast or was he slow um
they said if i they want to get it done
in two weeks so i have to pay them an
additional 600.
okay so um 1200 12
um 1200 plus v80 and if i want to
have it happen in two weeks then i need
to pay enough how expensive that is
600. i mean that might be
the price now i'm sure there's a high
demand there is a high demand there's
only a few of them in the country
yeah but if you do need other solicitors
to do these options i can connect you to
other people that will do it yeah i mean
i i
just i assume that was a price i i
already factored in my head that was
going to be two thousand pounds
is that high yeah yeah i mean it's a big
property and stuff and yeah it's
important you get it drawn up right and
you get drunk
yeah but it is hard yeah yeah normally
it's about grand
oh yeah it's 1200 including v8
no really high man
they're busy they are yeah they must be
i thought they're either going to be
really slow or they're going to be
expensive and yeah
it's the latter yeah um okay great so
you okay
so so you've literally since i last saw
you at the last property
you've refurbished it pretty much done
yeah you've got a big lease option
agreement that's going to give you a
thousand pounds a month profit
which we're just waiting on paperwork
you've got this
going on and you've got another you're
killing it literally i am being pulled
from every single place but
it's you know it's all a blessing like i
can't even
yeah and it's like it's almost like like
the reason
why you tell us to go out there look for
properties look through everything is
because
because this lease option agreement was
months ago but it's come now
you know what i mean it's like if you
just keep
at it like the amount of floodgates that
i'm just getting right now is
unbelievable i don't know what like god
has got in store but
it's just honest to god things are just
coming in every single window
yeah and i'm actually having to make
sure that my neck doesn't have any holes
in it so that i can catch all this fish
because it's just going mad
yeah in in every area would it be worth
potentially i'm thinking out loud um
me and you might be like i've already
got it covered because you've got your
architect's different stuff
but if you want me to like properly
properly go over the deals
and check or you can't are you
comfortable with them i mean as far as i
think the only one that i have i mean
the delete the
the lease option agreement um
you know keith lee isn't the biggest
area in the world um
like you know you've gone to bedroom
there's like like
30 ads like it's not the biggest highest
amount who's going
to rent the rooms out sorry um your move
will be managing it your move will be
managing it as a hmo
yeah okay so it needs to get obviously
anything
are you gonna have to get right into
every more room will you be competing
onto a company or what
it'll be rented out run by them as a hm
it hasn't got a license so i have to put
planning in
what why did you choose your move
because they
basically said that they've got loads of
people
in the area yeah that literally they
were like calling my phone
um like every week so you spoke to any
other hm management i've spoken to
another one
um what they called again
there's a couple there's like maybe
three like main ones in the area i would
speak two of them definitely
yeah and just see what they said because
your move high street letting it's
usually a bit crap
yeah you have this before yeah they're
usually really really bad
so i'm not saying anything you're on
with wood bay
all right cool that's great i feel like
i need a pen and paper now though
yeah you've got a pen and paper i think
so um
yeah yeah i'm really really pleased
um so moving forward you've got multiple
deals
in the bag yeah you've got a lot going
on how do you how do you feel
like emotion and stuff are you good or
are you stressed oh oh i was crumbling a
couple yeah yeah like when you called me
yesterday were you crumbling yeah yeah i
was crashing and burning but in a good
way
you know um but sometimes like i already
know the answer
you know and i'll call but i already
know what i need to do well normally
when you call me up for advice i'll go
well what do you think
yeah i think this this is a lot yeah i
think you know
it's just having someone to bounce
something off definitely but you will
turn around and say to me jl to be
honest i think that a
self-contained flat is worth more yeah
so that would make me and at the end of
the day i've got the bridge until
january so
yeah i'm all right i can rent it out
they can pay for the bridge you know
it's a bit delayed but it'll be fine i'm
i'm sorry you'll be fine i think
keep calling me if you get stuck yeah
keep me posted when i see your calls and
voice notes and stuff i always think
yes i don't ever think like oh man ever
keep contacting me if you need any help
now you need to focus on number one you
need to focus on
managing what you've got going on now
yeah you've got this
you could try and get planning for the
loft you'll see planning for that
it looks good we've got your multiple
deals you
reefer that you're just finishing off so
manage what we've got
number two deal source i'm doing it like
crazy good
actually i've got four deals out
two of them already potentially sold
already today that's amazing yeah
literally i've got uh the same person or
separate people um
well there's two there's two different
because i'm actually selling some to
private and some two sources as well so
i've got sources on it
so they're actually one of them's
actually coming up monday and tuesday
just come and have a look at it
builders are coming over and everything
so it's all working out really well
you're taking these up front yeah i am
have you taken the money off there no
no yeah before you meet them take the
money oh really yeah
otherwise they'll waste your time what
the sauce is
oh hold on sorry what sauces are coming
the sword yeah sources are coming
you don't send them straight to
investors some some i'm sending to
investors some of them send into stores
who are the sources
um ot okay is one of them
um jamal is another one yeah he's good
yeah
and then evans i work with evans really
really nice
i love evans literally i love that one
yes okay cool
so deal sourcing yes and then it's
really good and then
i want to up your thermostat come down
come to leeds
yeah let me show you my site only down
the road from me and bradford
we've just we're negotiating an option
to build 30 houses
oh my god come down and see yeah i want
to be a part of that raise
your mindset yeah and now you went from
100 grand profit to 200 grand profit but
we need to get into that millionaire
yeah i think we need to go a little bit
bigger yeah but how are you killing it
so well honestly um i reckon you're
halfway there
i think so that's how i feel i feel like
soon i'm going to come back to london
i feel like in like six months from now
i'm gonna move back home and i think
once you're a millionaire
yeah so you move up north become a
millionaire come back and then come back
and then
live the life yeah that's i mean that's
that's what you teach isn't it
um yeah anything else is there anything
you need for me right now um so do you
think that this is a good
opportunity do you think it's worth
doing
do you think i should put the money into
another property i
okay how long does it how long have you
got the planning for
until july this year
you could reapply quite easily yeah i
could with 35 grand
and you can have the hassle just to make
35 grand i guess you are doubling your
money
it probably is worth doing i'm just not
excited about it because it's a small
manner
i'm not excited but then where would the
fifth grade go do you know what i mean
what do you mean like you'd either buy
another house for like
two hundred thousand pounds you know
less even maybe a hundred and yeah
because of stamp duty and everything so
where else would it be is it yeah
because everything else is happening go
on there go on then
you have permission to extend your flat
thank you anyway hey it's been a real
pleasure ready
good i'll see you later okay i didn't
make you a cup of tea
we don't care how does the world how do
you want me to
just take pictures of the house when
it's all done
um no i'll come see it you want to come
and see it
okay perfect lovely
are you still coming yeah
all right bye i'll see you okay